デッドリーだよねでセミナーしたあった確実に上がったんですけどもそばを蹴るのも
ちょっとね辛くなりました
これじゃあ所社長です皆さんパインのみというものをご存じでしょう
まあそれはそれは有名なお菓子ですよ
現物がことになるんですけどもチョコレートパイのパスですねこれみんな知って樹
さすがにまだ中にチョコが入ってて美味しいパイのパスなんですけども
ネットでめっちゃ話題になってなんですけどもこれの17倍の大きさのパイの実でに集
が発売されたんですよ
それはこちらうわぁ
パー子はパパシャーパパワーを一杯飲み見たいなぁで2周
[拍手]
やっぱりのみ約17枚
ん
そんだけなんですけどこんだけなんですけど
周防きたてくだなんてがめっちゃパイドになんですよ開けますね
[音楽]
5分ちゃんと六角形出す横から見てもちゃんと杯飲みだし
後ろとかも長に出るんですよ熱烈時各社よりばかりスイートなんですけどこれフラ実物
ですねこんな感じ
確かに言われていればちょっとでニーチェっぽい生地ではあるんですよ
並べてみましょうかおおすごい色がでしょ
やすごいねまずでき
んですよやっぱちゃんと公式で作ってからめちゃくちゃ生地の色とかのそっくりなん
ですよ
本当に大きさが17倍で違うだけいただきます
なおの紗絵子さは凄い本当にロッテさんあれの大万
私にとっても良いことを思いつきました鈍感な人と絶対いるんですよ
パイの実が17倍の大きさになっても気付かないような鈍感な人間が一緒にいるとき
パイの実食べ続けるんですけども
指でポテト食べてるパイの実の桜期間が空くとずうな場合になってても
バレンがいい気がしてるんですよねまあ人によってですけど普通の人じゃ引き続きます
よこれがこうなっちゃうわけですからさすがに気づくんですけれども鈍感な人は気づか
ないですと
さすがに馬鹿にしてるかねぇ駄文気付かないと思うよね
ストや顕微鏡などが良い方はれするとバカな後輩ば惨敗のパイの実伸びたら17になっ
ても気づくか気づかないことをやっていきたいとおもいます
ちぇっ t
ます
th
こんなにランナー
[音楽]
はいセッティング完了でございますジェントがやらせれば多分
式がそれるのでさすがにストレートにやりすぎるとバレると思うんで徐々にハードルを
上げていこうと思いますでは検証開始
[音楽]
さあ俺が髪にしても買ったら入れずんです
あそぼ前世とっ
2時間を得られますロシア人2時間走減税いっ
おっとここでん
おっとワーク雅夜をああああ
そう
スペイただツアーやつですのでお勧めしかっていうメシクの的夏天だったんっ
よしやっちゃあやっちゃうよ
[音楽]
最新の舞部5になりにおっですせー
うまくねー
沼です
ますでございます
あーはいはいいるはまあまあ2期からでいいよってをますジロッ
ヤバイって言ってい
[音楽]
hype
ワッツ
[音楽]
パンッのズバリし
ぽんぽんぽんバー1を6ポンプリー
じゃん hey
[拍手]
ええええええ
おっしゃ
ラジオ対策を割って話す
うん
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
なんかこういう動かすくれた上からブリッジと率は確かに最も違ってください
[音楽]
お相手の技バカッ
バンバンですね
はありません
はい前ファイアー4 at ぺー
ふぁいふぁいてぃん
パンッ apeman デー
car
ああああああ
大
pp えーいピザバーガー
per pon pon pon 2
しれる
[音楽]
はいはいはいよろしいですよ
バーッ
あああああ
行動せん
me
ううっフォンの
バーリー
バッハ
[音楽]
ブーブーんっ
たえっって黒ねー
皮膚ぐね駄目なんじゃなーんか言っちゃうと
サースガード恵著ちゃんジェミ11ゲイはいて中古けば
たづらにダメだったがこれはバカでも傷がある
はい
前ファイアーよ atk ぺーあっはぁ挨拶って守る
あっ